il prépare l'enfumoir pour disperser les
abeilles même si l approche de l'hiver
et par temps pluvieux les russes sont
plutôt calmes
ce qui n'empêche pas quelques frelons
asiatiques de rodez en quête de proies
après la saison des récoltes jason
augusto fait le tour de ses ruches et
pour peser chaque unité
cette pesée elle nous permet d'avoir un
indicatif de la santé de la colonie donc
de la population les réserves
c'est-à-dire que si elles ont plus du
tout de ressources de miel dans la ruche
on est obligés d'amener un substitut à
150 ruches disséminés en sologne ainsi
qu'un espace dédié à l'élevage de rennes
et dessins ce jeune apiculteur a choisi
un modèle qu'il veut à taille humaine
travailleurs en forêt lui permet de
viser la certification happy culture
biologique
autour de chaque ruche de chaque ruche
est donc un ensemble de ruches
il faut qu'on est sur trois kilomètres à
la ronde
aucune agriculture conventionnelle la
soudaine il plutôt bien bien garni en en
floraison intéressante pour apiculture
donc la saison va commencer avec du son
aux pruneaux dié aubépines bourdaines
ensuite acacias de la ronce du
châtaignier en attendant de disposer de
sa propre miellerie jason augusto mais
parfois à contribution la maison de ses
parents pour la mise en pot différents
miels pâte à tartiner confiserie la
production est vendue sous l'appellation
la demoiselle de sologne
on essaye à commercialiser tout au long
de la saison donc on fait un marché à
peu près tous les quinze jours sur
marché de tiji est également
on commercialise dans des points de
vente épiceries ou chez d'autres
agriculteurs qui comprend également
leurs produits qui en échange aussi
bandes des nôtres et on a également des
notes notre boulanger du village qui
nous achètent du miettes pour faire des
bénéfices après une année 2010 9
difficile du fait de la sécheresse avec
ses deux tonnes de miel la récolte
prolifique de 2020 devrait aider jason
augusto à pérenniser son activité